Howard Schultz bought Starbucks in 1987
and built it into a global powerhouse in
the coffee business from the beginning
he put a strong emphasis on the
company's commitment to social issues
and strengthening communities now first
on CBS this morning Schultz is launching
the second season of Starbucks original
series upstanders it features people who
have taken action to make their
communities better the first episode
focuses on a chef who risked his career
to open a restaurant staffed almost
exclusively by former juvenile detention
inmates I was inundated with reasons why
I was going to fail the kids are gonna
stab each other in the kitchen the kids
don't want to work the kids just want to
collect the check the kids are gonna try
to sell drugs in the restaurant I was
betting my entire career on taking kids
to teach them to play with knives and
fire
[Music]
hold on
is a family I feel like I can have the
worst day and I can come in here and be
crying and like broke it down to tears
and they can help me and lift me up and
make me feel better and make me forget
all about it just like a mustard green
huh that might actually be mustard
greens upstanders is produced by Howard
Schultz who is also executive chairman
of Starbucks and we're happy to welcome
back to the table good morning Howard
Thank You Dora I chose to you morning
good morning so this second series
features stories from all across the
country what's the goal
I'm the goal is there's a better side to
America than what's coming out of
Washington those stories are not being
told upstanders ones that season 60
million people viewed that series I
think it's even more relevant today I
think the sense of humanity compassion
empathy that's going on in every city in
every town around the country has to be
told and we had so many stories we
picked eleven we could have had a
thousand and I think people are longing
for truth authenticity you just talked
about Millennials it's an altruistic
generation they want to hear stories
like this and I think we have a false
narrative in America which is coming out
of Washington which is not the American
story not the promise of America so
Starbucks in its sense with our platform
of almost a hundred million customers a
week are just sharing these stories and
I think people are embracing it so
what's the pulse narrative of Washington
well the false narrative is that the
divisive nough stupor zation and
dysfunction the lack of leadership is
not America it's it's going on in
Washington but the divisive nasteria day
we have so many stories that we've shown
in which there there are differences of
opinion on a number of issues but people
come together we met a woman in Missoula
Montana one of the stories Mary cool
against all odds no training whatsoever
against the lay the mentality in Montana
and she brings refugees from Syria I
mean these are people who are upstanders
people who are not listening to
Washington doing the kind of things that
I think speak to the American story so
you hope
to give recognition to all the good
stories but also by recognizing the good
stories you may change behavior in
Washington no I mean I don't think
Starbucks is in the business of changing
behavior in Washington but I think we
have an opportunity a really important
opportunity to demonstrate that the
country needs a more compassionate
society and a more compassionate
government and in fact it is going on
every day I mentioned in the green room
to Newt Gingrich I just came back from
Normandy and III was leaving the
cemetery which is such a sobering
experience and I was as I was leaving I
met this woman from Baltimore and I
asked her why why are you here and she
said my husband and I came here to be
reminded of who we once were
yeah that's been incredibly moving and I
think you know I love this country as we
all do and I think we're right now and
facing a real crucible in terms of our
society and the lack of leadership in
Washington and I know there's a better
side to America and we have an
opportunity to show it so there are
people who think about you as a
potential presidential candidate my
question is you know if that was true is
this the kind of narrative that you want
to articulate well I'm not running for
president charlie but the narrative that
I'd like to try and elevate is the fact
that our society needs to be reminded
that Washington does not define our
behavior that we define our behavior and
that we can make changes and every
single day around the country people
ordinary people are doing extraordinary
things and and the media should shine a
light on that this wasn't your version
of a listening tour the way Hillary
Clinton went on the listening tour
before announcing her candidacy well not
at all because we have stores almost in
every community in America I'm on the
road all the time I was in Houston three
weeks ago and and saw the devastation
that's part of my job interesting enough
you know people coming together and
Houston is wonderful but that's
happening not because of a catastrophe
it's happening because of human kindness
and that's going on every day in America
we don't need a hurricane to demonstrate
the values in you man
the country well you can see that
because every time there is this kind of
national response to a disaster or a
tragedy you see the same kind of conduct
whatever the community is yeah but I'm
also saying I see this I see without
without the tragedy yes I just yes but
we but it's not being told and
unfortunately the the tonality coming
out of Washington and the lack of
civility the lack of respect defines a
narrative are you putting it at the feet
of the president no I mean I don't I
think I'm putting it I mean listen we've
had polarization dysfunction in
Washington for a number of years
unfortunately it's gotten to a boiling
point now where it's almost impossible
to wake up every day because you've got
a different episodic situation and it
does place a cloud over our society and
I want to offset that by saying there's
something else going on a better America
good for you yeah thank you thank you
for coming nice to have you in your
heart